Shani Zanescu, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Good, thank you for having me.
With the huge list of remarkable people,
I'll try to reach up the bar, yeah.
I'll try, I'll try.
I am extremely excited
for this conversation.
Shani, besides the fact
that you're the founder
of Isratech Ventures,
which we'll of course, dive into,
I think talking about your journey
is extremely relevant and interesting.
Because like you mentioned
right before we started talking,
your entrance to the tech world
as an Israeli is not that perhaps,
traditional startup nation,
the classic story of 8200, elite unit,
whatever, and then going into the tech.
You had a multitude
of really fascinating positions
with embassies, with diplomats.
So, Shani, who are you?
And then later on, we'll dive into
what Isratech Ventures is about.
Yeah. Well, I always like
to start my story
in a town called Fort Worth, Texas.
Yeah. A Christian university.
Yeah. But beforehand,
I guess it all begins
with a dramatic day
that my parents told me
the worst thing that you can tell
to a 15 year old living in Israel,
surrounded with friends,
I grew up in Misgav,
which is like a kibbutz,
like it's really the best place to live.
Where we have one of the best
robotics team in Israel.
Yes, that's true.
So, it was very dramatic.
I thought it was the end of the world
for a teenager to say,
"Hey, we're moving to Fort Worth, Texas."
I had no idea what this place was.
And then indeed one thing led to another.
And I was bumped to class.
So, I went straight into my senior year
and then started applying to colleges
because this is what you do in the US,
right?
And I didn't really know English.
At the beginning
I didn't want to speak with everyone
because I was angry, right?
Yeah.
But then I didn't have a choice.
And the first happy thing
was that I realized
that I can get my license,
driving license before everyone else.
So, it was the first good sign.
And then one thing led to another.
And I got into Texas Christian University,
which is a private university.
And it was I mean,
it was such a different experience
than all of my other friends.
And I mean, it was a great experience.
Some of my best friends for life,
obviously, were my roommates
and yada yada.
And then, I had a choice,
about what should I do.
Because my parents went back to Israel.
We were there on a relocation.
So, at the age of the 17,
I did my first intuitive decision.
I didn't know
that it's called intuition back then.
And it was to decide to stay by myself
in Fort Worth, Texas,
to complete my degree.
Because all of my family
went back to Israel.
And I'm glad I did that.
I decided to also,
another intuitive decision was,
to come back to Israel
and still do my military service
even though I was 21,
which is old for military here.
So, you finished your degree in the US
and then you came
and you essentially volunteered
or did your military service
back in Israel?
I did my regular military service.
The only thing was my mind was wired
like when you're about
to graduate from college, they're like,
you can do whatever you want.
And I started sending my CV
to places in the military,
which no one does in Israel.
Like I started it.
And then I ended up
in the foreign affairs unit.
And then I decided
that I want to be an ambassador
and I want to connect people to Israel,
and I want to do all these things
and all that jazz.
What was it about the experience
in the foreign affairs unit
that made you say,
I want to be an ambassador
and I want to be a diplomat for now?
I think that it was something
that still accompanies me
until this very day,
and that is that, it just feels like
I'm a part of something bigger.
And I know,
I bet a lot of people say it to you,
but this is for me
the one of the most strongest motives
for me to do things.
Like I like to be a part of something
and over there it was a daily thing
that you're doing small stuff,
but you know the repercussions of that.
So, it's very thrilling to me.
And then, I also recognize
that it's a passion of mine
to connect people to Israel
in like a non cynical way.
Because everyone around me
was cynical about it.
But it's like something I recognize there.
So, I did the obvious thing that people
in the foreign affairs unit do
after they're done.
And I moved again to the Netherlands,
to The Hague,
and I was assistant defense attaché there.
So, I did what I wanted to do.
It was a great experience,
but it was too cold
so I decided to come back.
But honestly, it was lonely, too.
It's lonely, to be honest.
And I also realized
that I don't want to be an ambassador.
I'm guessing it's not just the location
that is perhaps less lively
than the city of Tel Aviv, which is one
of the liveliest place in the world.
But it's also the fact
that you're alone there, right?
I mean, you're living
straight out of the army.
A lot of people go to university together
or move to Tel Aviv together.
And if you're going to a different place,
yeah, I completely understand.
Yeah. And everyone at the embassy
were couples and families.
And it's just like
you get the point of it.
And I was already very independent,
so I kind of like experienced.
I traveled a lot around Europe,
I lived in the States.
So, at the very young age,
I was already just taking the boxes
on a lot of things that I wanted to do.
Right.
So, I moved back to Israel.
And I didn't know what I was going to do
so, I signed up for a masters degree.
Right, this is what we do.
And then I started looking for a job
and it was like a culture shock.
It was interesting
because I was coming back
to my own country,
but I was still experiencing
all the culture shocks that I've heard
that other people felt.
Like I felt like an ulla, almost.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Wow.
Even though you served in the IDF,
even though you grew up in a kibbutz,
you felt like an ulla.
Kind of, yeah.
Because you need
to rebuild your life again.
And I had friends
and I'm very good
at keeping touch with people,
but there are a lot of struggles.
And you do have more comfortable lives
if you live in Europe or in the US,
I'm sure you're aware.
And you need to give up
all the comfort things
that are very obvious
when you live abroad and not in Israel.
So, it's even in the small things
and in your day to day stuff.
And also, I get back and I didn't know
what I was doing with my life.
And after the whole bam, bam,
I'm doing this and doing that,
and you're like,
"Why everyone is saying to me
I'm overqualified for jobs?"
"What does that even mean?"
You start realizing that you need to do
some work on yourself.
And that was for me the point.
So, talk to me a little bit
about the transition
from diplomacy and foreign affairs
to Israeli tech.
Because that sounds
like a little odd transition.
Especially because it sounds like
there was a point where you did
a little bit abruptly.
Yeah. Well, so when I got back,
I started working at the British Council.
And I started as a project manager
and I moved up to be
the head of the department.
And in this organization,
they do collaborations with the UK
on various of sectors.
And one of the sectors
is research and science and innovation.
I think that was for me,
like the gling gling gling,
when I realized that I'm a nerd.
Like, wow, science is amazing.
Technology is like mind blowing.
There are people here
who are doing amazing stuff.
And this whole idea of
continuing to promote Israel
through tech is there.
So, after three years there,
I also managed an innovation center.
And I wasn't there for a very long time.
But I think there,
it was the first time in my life
that I worked with entrepreneurs.
And you speak to a lot of entrepreneurs,
I'm assuming,
so you know that spark in their eye
and that passion,
it's something that is completely
like it sucks you in,
you want to be around with people
and there's no way back.
So, from working with ministers
and CEOs and high levels,
which was I still do that,
it's great,
but it didn't feel the same.
So, I left and like every good story,
a friend of mine
gave me a kick in the butt to come
to one of the delegation of investors
that wanted to be introduced
to some startups,
and it started from there.
And it just happened naturally.
I know it's not a good recipe
or something that people
might be able to follow, but for me,
the transition wasn't a one day
that I decided that I'm going to do it.
It wasn't a role.
It was a very gradual process.
And from meeting all the delegations
that come to Israel
and are craving meeting
the best people, the best technologies,
want to hear more about it,
I also started doing consulting
to innovation programs
and accelerators and hubs,
and all these angel investors
wanted me to work with them.
And then it really led me
to work with one specific investor
that I'm working with also today
that is again doing something huge,
that is much bigger than me.
So, the transition was very gradual.
It wasn't sudden.
You mentioned clearly
and you alluded a few times
to this idea that helping Israel
through tech and innovation,
because you're coming
from the foreign affairs segment.
And I'd love to dive into this
a little bit, because I think
it's really interesting.
A lot of people are talking about Israel
as a startup nation
and innovation through necessity,
no place for small dreams, right?
And I'm curious about the role
on the diplomatic side
and the foreign affairs side on Israel
being a startup nation.
So, what is the importance of that?
And give me a little bit of insight
into the back seat
of the diplomacy scene.
Wow.
So, I've seen it
in all sorts of angles.
So, I first saw it
from the defense angle, okay?
And there it's like it sounds weird,
but it's very safe.
Israel is like the go to place
for defense technologies,
[--].
Everyone wants to work with Israel,
even if they're not admitting it.
Okay?
And it was very interesting to me
because I saw how people,
colleagues from all around the world
are craving so much to work with Israel,
but they're afraid to do so.
And I think, coming from the
startups and technologies,
it's much more legitimate thing
because people are just looking
for solutions for XYZ,
and you know that they find it here.
And I think what's interesting for me,
now and always,
was to be in this intersection
of being the one who's either
initiating or supporting
or accompanying the collaborations
and bringing in government.
Because you need everything.
So, the government role,
the private money,
which is extremely important,
you can't really do anything,
you can have a lot of plans
but you need that private money,
and all the other players.
So, the private sector,
the public sector, some NGOs even.
And I think for me,
I was always in this intersection.
And when I decided to go ahead
on my own freelance way
with Isratech Venture,
it was really from the purpose
of shining this intersection
and making it more accessible to people.
With the emphasis of bringing investments
to all these amazing startups.
And for me that is the best service
that I can do for my country,
to bring in that foreign money.
So, is that really
what the goal of Isratech is,
to bring in partners across the seas
from different cultures
and different backgrounds
to support Israeli tech innovation?
Yeah. So, along the years,
I really realized
that I accumulated a network of,
I truly mean it, remarkable people
from all around the world.
And in conversations,
we always had this like,
okay, so how do we begin;
how do we start this collaboration;
and I know this investor,
I know this minister,
like it was so disorganize to me.
And I knew that I could just,
if I have my own platform, I'm like,
I don't owe anything to anyone, really,
I can just do the great connections
that I want to do.
So, to be honest,
it's just a platform for me
to play around
and do whatever I love,
which is to connect all these people
who are very influential
from all around the world,
and in the process support startups
that I truly admire and truly love
and want an excuse
to work with them to invest.
Yeah.
That sounds so so cool.
So, give me a little bit of background
about your experience right now with this.
So, what part of this
really makes you
really passionate about this
in the day to day?
Is it meeting the startups?
Is it the meeting the people
outside of Israel and connecting,
seeing the connections unfold?
Because I'm guessing that
a lot of the times the connections,
while they're being made
through Isratech Ventures,
they expand much further than that
as they go on these
longer term collaborations.
So, which part of it
do you get really excited about?
So, pre covid-19,
we have two parts of the [--].
So, covid-19 I really enjoyed,
I had these marathon days
of meeting 10 startups a day
like boom boom boom,
And sometimes it was very boring
and sometimes exciting,
I met so many people.
It really like it's a certain energy
that is can be really exhausting
but can really nurture you as well,
depends on who you are meeting.
And I was working
in a very very quick pace.
Nowadays, and I had all these
incoming delegations,
and come right here and come right there,
it was a different vibe.
And I just enjoyed
the whole complex of that.
Nowadays, I think what I enjoy most
is to really work with the companies,
with the startups.
So, I am on some boards
and working with portfolio companies
of the investor I'm working with.
And it's really interesting to me
to really dive in to the company.
And, half of the time I'm only listening
because I'm trying to understand
how I can help them
and not to jump and be like,
hey, I connect you to this and this.
It's like something that in Israel
we love to do,
to really soak in where they are,
what they need and try to help them,
again, by connecting them
to both my network
and anything else that they need.
So, I think for me,
it's really something
what I enjoy most now.
And it's also a time when you really
you kind of deepening
every aspect of your life.
So, I think for me also at work
and you're just everything is more calm.
So, I'm trying to enjoy it
because the craziness will return, right?
100%.
Shani, 20 minutes ago by very very fast.
And I think it's wonderful to hear about
somebody's journey
coming from outside of the tech world
and finding passion within it
and finding the right foothold
and making a really positive impact,
not just on entrepreneurs,
but also on the state of Israel
as a whole.
So, thank you for that.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you
for the most important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Wow. Last week, I learned a new word
from a friend
that I think really describes me
and probably people already saw it
because you read people's energy,
you can't really define them in words,
right?
So, the word was vivacious.
Okay.
I didn't know this word.
You're learning something new.
And I think
the second word would be, a creator.
Okay.
And I think the last
and most important word
would be, heart.
Wholehearted, heart led,
I think it's what describes me the best.
I love it.
Shani, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Best of luck with Isratech Ventures
and all the wonderful work
that you're doing.
And I'm very excited to share this
with the world.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
Bye Bye.
Bye.